To retire or not retire.
That is the question
still swarming around
Senator Dianne Feinstein.
The 89 year old California
Democrat is vowing to stay in office
through her term
despite being confined to a wheelchair
as she recovers
from a series of health issues.
The New York Times reporting since
returning to Washington,
Feinstein has missed six votes
and has not participated in any committee
hearings or caucus lunches.
And The Washington Post
speaking to a divided California
Democratic delegates over the weekend.
This is from one from Rosemary Williams,
and she's
just following orders
as best she can at this point.
She's not herself.
Marcia Conant, on the other hand, said
it's extraordinary her career.
And I think that's getting minimized
and that makes me angry.
Now, Feinstein,
the issues have been
happening for some time.
She just suffered shingles
and related issues with it.
After she came back.
She didn't deny
she had broader health complications.
And then
she did have
broader health complications.
As we reported on May 9th.
But she also had a memory issues
that she suffered for some time.
She was pushed aside
as the top Democrat
on the Senate Judiciary Committee.
She passed up being the president
pro tem,
which is for the most senior
member of the majority party.
Patty Murray now has that.
So these are issues that have been
that she's been dealing with
for some time.
Can she sustained this?
So I think there are two things at play.
And unfortunately,
the politics is one of them.
And we can't ignore that.
We can't ignore that.
She has a crew,
even though she's no longer
the top Democrat on Judiciary.
She's a crucial deciding vote
on that
very important committee,
especially in this divided government,
where so much of what
Democrats can accomplish
is focused
on confirming judges
and other Biden appointees.
So I think Democrats need Feinstein
and there will create a lot of headaches
if she were to step down.
Governor Newsom doesn't want the headache
that would be created if she steps down.
And it also seems pretty clear that
whether you agree or not,
she has decided
she does not want to step down.
But I think the other thing
that a lot of people have brought up,
there's been some criticism
that just
from a health standpoint,
from a wellness standpoint,
should the best thing for Senator
Feinstein be to serve out,
to not serve out her term, instead
just kind of be able to go home and rest
and not have the stress
of being in the U.S.
And it's been a staff ordeal,
as The New York Times reports.
They say that MS.
Feinstein staff has made sure she is
never alone and is heavily protected.
The Capitol Police
and the Senate sergeant arms
have gone to great lengths to keep MS.
Feinstein, shielded
from photographers and reporters,
helping to create a bubble around her
as aides run interference on her behalf.
I mean, I have personally experience
that too.
I've tried to be in positions
where we try to get video over.
They said that these are places
you're not allowed to get video of her.
They've tried
intentionally trying
to avoid press scrutiny.
Obviously, this is unusual
given the access
we typically have on the Hill.
Absolutely.
That is extremely rare,
and it really does show
how Cognizant staff, I'm
sure her family, those around her
are about
just general press coverage
and how people are seeing her.
I mean, it was a shock to so many people
when they opened the car door,
as you see right there.
And she arrived to the Senate
for the first time after months.
She just looked so frail.
The thing about the Senate, though,
and you have a really good point about,
you know,
the votes
and just needing to have someone there
tapping someone new would
possibly make it
a little difficult
in terms of timing of votes and,
you know, having all those people there.
But we've seen this time
and time again with a number of senators.
You know,
this is not that rare
that many of them wish to be there
for, Kelly,
until the day
they get a perfect Segway
because this is indeed not an age old.
It is an age old issue
to look at just a few headlines
from the past 2001,
a report about the 100 year
old Strom
Thurmond in the office, 2009
from someone named one a Roger,
a Politico pro Byrd illness,
Cho's fragile majority.
She was my age as well.
And then also our industrious reporter,
Ted Barrett on Capitol
Hill in October 2017 about Thad Cochran
who ultimately resigned from office.
Robert Byrd was 92 after serving
51 years.
Nancy Pelosi says it's sexism
to go after Feinstein.
But this is really an issue
that's been happening for so many years.
It definitely has as long
as we've been covering the Hill.
The Strom Thurmond once you know
most particularly he could barely exist
he was living at Walter Reed,
if I recall,
and still serving the Senate.
Look, the difference
here is the narrow majority
and the fact that she serves
on an important committee,
the Judiciary Committee
as you were saying.
So I think that is what's at issue here.
If she was simply on other committees
or if it was another senator
whose vote
wasn't as critical
or if Democrats had more breathing room,
we wouldn't be talking about this.
And it's politics.
What is different?
The politics in California
is so fascinating
because we have already
had a race to replace her
in a new somewhere
to just pick a replacement
and he has promised to pick a black woman
while there is a black woman
in the race, probably.
And perhaps if he gave her
the replacement,
could give a leg up against Adam Schiff,
who Nancy Pelosi supports.
Other supports.
Katie Porter
could give up a leg up against her.
Who knows if he'd pick Barbara Lee.
But still,
there are politics at play here, right?
Because regardless,
he said he'll pick a black woman,
which even if it's not Barbara
Lee, and quite frankly,
it would be hard for him to pick
Barbara Lee,
given the fact that Adam Schiff
and Katie Porter are also in the race in
Nobody wants to have that perception
as putting their thumb
on the scale of such
an important Senate seat for Democrats.
But then if it's not Barbara Lee,
then it becomes well, who is it?
And then that creates a whole nother
discussion in California.
So, again,
I think Governor Newsom would
rather not have that on his plate.
But that means that Senator Feinstein
remains in office through 20, 24.
We'll see if the Senate comes back
this week. We'll see what happens then.